durant tout le mois de janvier TV 78
reçoit les maires de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines pour parler
des grands projets de l'année 2023 et ce
soir nous recevons François Morton
bonsoir vous êtes le maire de la commune
de Guyancourt vous allez présenter vos
vœux au Guyancourtois et guyancourtoise
le 14 janvier alors qu'est-ce que vous
allez évoquer avec eux on va faire
évidemment un petit bilan de cette année
écoulé avec l'ensemble des mesures qu'on
a dû les uns et les autres et
particulièrement à Guyancourt mettre en
place je vais pas refaire l'histoire de
ces dernières années mais pour un
certain nombre d'entre nous nous sommes
les maires du covid de la guerre de la
crise énergétique et donc on commence
habitué à être habitué un petit peu
assez crises et on réagit concrètement
et rapidement avec beaucoup de
réactivité dans les communes je pense
notamment à la mise en place de
nouvelles aides énergétiques pour nos
habitants des aides qui par le passé
relevé d'autres collectivités mais
maintenant qui qui sont des aides
communales je pense aux allocations
d'énergie pour les personnes âgées pour
les familles monoparentales que nous
venons d'inaugurer cette année par le
fait évidemment ou
détendre encore une fois
aux personnes notamment en situation de
handicap également nous allons accélérer
aussi l'ensemble des réhabilitations des
bâtiments publics parce que ça a plus
long terme c'est une nécessité absolue
dans les mois et des années qui viennent
sur Guyancourt deux groupes scolaires
vont être totalement réhabiliter nous
avons évidemment participé à l'effort
collectif en termes d'éclairage de
choses comme ça au sein de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc ça c'est
très important le très court terme parce
que c'est diverses crises ont fragilisé
encore plus les populations qui étaient
déjà fragilisées voilà on va continuer à
les fragiliser probablement avec la
réforme des retraites mais c'est un
autre sujet effectivement et donc on se
doit de réagir et les communes sont en
première rideaux de toutes ces
fragilités le maire et le premier lien
avec les habitants est-ce que vous avez
beaucoup d'habitants aujourd'hui qui
viennent vous voir et qui sont fortement
touchés par cette hausse du du coût des
énergies oui c'est très flagrant voilà
pour vous donner une petite idée alors
quelques chiffres simplement très
rapidement on a dû augmenter nos aides
de 50 % dans le cadre des budgets des
CCAS du budget du CCAS par exemple avec
l'ensemble des aides que j'ai parce que
elle est c'est fragilité encore une fois
elles sont concrètes et elles sont
immédiates voilà les répercussions je
pars notamment des des habitants du parc
social de la ville ont vu leur provision
de charge immédiatement augmenter de
manière très importante très importante
et ces personnes qui étaient déjà
fragilisées encore une fois ne
l'oublions jamais voilà le son encore
davantage et d'ailleurs en septembre
dernier vous aviez à interpellé des
bailleurs sur la hausse du prix du
chauffage alors où est-ce que ça en est
ce dossier il avance doucement trop trop
doucement à mon goût voilà pour
l'instant il y a assez peu de
propositions concrètes et immédiates on
va dire sonnant et trébuchante pour pour
être tout à fait franc en revanche je
pense qu'il y a une prise de conscience
réelle du fait d'accélérer les processus
de réhabilitation énergétique voilà mais
là on a encore une fois on est un peu
plus dans le moyen terme voir pour
certains dans le plus long terme alors
dans les autres grands projets pour la
commune en 2023 il y a le réaménagement
du quartier des savoirs depuis 2021 vous
êtes en concertation avec les habitants
alors quelles sont les thématiques qui
les préoccupent le plus alors
effectivement on va lancer la phase 3 de
notre concertation entamée en 2021 je le
rappelle très rapidement on avait
souhaité une grande concertation très
large et très en amont de l'arrivée des
premières entreprises
et donc ça fonctionne bien on a fait un
certain nombre d'ateliers de balade
urbaine aussi et les thèmes les thèmes
effectivement qui intéressent le plus
nos habitants c'est évidemment
l'aménagement de ce quartier soyons très
clairs va-t-il y avoir des services
publics la réponse est évidemment oui du
logement c'était évident nous savons des
commerces de l'activité économique et
les habitants sont totalement associés à
cette concertation donc le 21 janvier il
y aura la troisième phase de cette
concertation qu'est-ce que vous allez
aborder avec eux concrètement alors
concrètement il y aura une annonce très
concrète pour le coup notre nouveau
quartier il dispose et c'est une vraie
chance d'un grand parc qui est déjà
présent bien évidemment et j'ai souhaité
que ce soit les habitants de Guyancourt
qui lui donnent son nom voilà et donc
j'annoncerai le 21 janvier donc
évidemment je ne vous le dirai pas
aujourd'hui le nom de ce parc il reste
deux noms il reste deux noms en course
c'est Simone Veil et Marie Curie
une femme
continue sur sa charte d'égalité oui et
nous continuerons encore alors en
parlant de nous pourquoi ce nom quartier
des savoirs
alors là aussi c'est un choix des
habitants Guyancourt nous avions procédé
de la même manière à l'époque par un
sondage et puis deux noms qui étaient en
finale je ne vous cache pas que là
immédiatement je ne me souviens même
plus du deuxième nom qui était qui était
en finale parce que le nom de quartier
des savoirs je pense qu'il y a une
référence évidente à l'activité qui
pouvait y avoir auparavant avec
l'entreprise Thalès aussi et puis je ne
vous cache pas que le fait d'aller vers
le savoir plutôt que vers le croire ou
la croyance me satisfait pleinement
autre projet d'envergure le Grand Paris
Express cette ligne de métro qui devrait
relier Orly à Versailles en 30 minutes
elle va passer par 50 ans en Yvelines et
par Guyancourt alors est-ce que est-ce
que c'est un chantier le chantier va
commencer d'ailleurs cette année comment
ça se prépare alors la Société du Grand
Paris va s'installer en 2023 voilà ça
c'est vraiment le début on va commencer
à voir des choses qui se passent
effectivement il va falloir commencer à
un moment donné à songer à creuser une
ligne de métro donc effectivement la va
s'installer on pourra le voir très très
concrètement parce qu'il y aura des des
palissades avec le nom de la Société du
Grand Paris etc
et puis on va dire que le travail un peu
masqué continue effectivement parce que
nous devons déterminer avec la Société
du Grand Paris avec l'aménageur qui est
l'établissement public d'aménagement de
Paris sacrée aussi il y a déterminer
quels sont les besoins quels seront les
besoins de ce nouveau quartier mais il
va commencer à se passer des choses
voilà les Jeux Olympiques dans dans
moins de deux ans ils auront lieu aussi
à aguyancourt sur le Golf National
pareil comment est-ce que vous vous
préparez à cette échéance alors on s'y
prépare aussi avec 50 ans en Yvelines
c'est aussi une concertation puisque les
sites olympiques sont aiguillon court
certes enfin le un site olympique à
Guyancourt mais il y en a d'autres
ailleurs dans des villes de
l'agglomération on s'y prépare il faut
qu'on crée l'événement il faut qu'on
enroule nos habitants vers cet échéance
de 2024 donc il y aura des choses cet
été par exemple à Guyancourt mais il y a
déjà eu l'été dernier un certain nombre
de manifestations autour des des Jeux
Olympiques nous avons la chance au-delà
du site olympique d'avoir un centre
préparatoire aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques qui sont les salles d'arts
martiaux du gymnase baquet on va
d'ailleurs en profiter pour en refaire
la piste d'athlétisme c'est aussi dans
nos projets de continuer à ça et on
espère avoir des visites de délégation
ça a déjà été le cas alors je n'ai pas
le droit de vous dire qui vient visiter
voilà ça fait partie des chartes
peut-être les avez-vous dans vos
informations je ne sais pas mais on a
des délégations déjà intéressées
2024 alors oui oui il y en a un alors
c'est évidemment avec ces populations
scolaires aussi qu'il faut qu'on
travaille on y avait déjà pensé
auparavant avec la création de la classe
golf au collège Les Saules par exemple
tous nos scolaires sont toujours
associés aux animations précédant les
événements des JO évidemment c'est
évidemment vers les scolaires qu'il faut
aller vous savez ce sont les scolaires
qui amènent leurs parents aux événements
alors sur le territoire de Guyancourt
l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines bientôt la
fusion en 2025 avec Paris Saclay est-ce
que c'est une chance pour Guyancourt
d'avoir l'UVSQ sur son territoire c'est
une chance inouïe alors je vais faire
attention par les médecines à côté de
mon cher collègue mais je ne veux pas
surtout pas dire de bêtises oui c'est
une chance et il faut que nous
travaillons encore davantage avec la
faculté de médecine notamment pour
toutes les mais je veux pas les exposer
ici mais c'est une question que nous
nous posons tous sur le fait de fixer de
de des médecins sur nos territoires et
donc il faut qu'on travaille avec la fac
quand même et alors pour terminer cette
entretien on va passer maintenant à
l'interview express
[Musique]
le principe François Marton 5 questions
et 5 réponses courtes nous poserons les
mêmes à tous les maires de
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors est-ce
que vous êtes prêts
dans votre commune non pour ou contre la
limitation de vitesse à 30 km/h dans
votre ville nous y pour ou contre
l'obligation du bio dans les cantines
alors on a déjà beaucoup travaillé je
vais pas dire juste oui ou non là parce
qu'on a déjà pris pas mal d'avance avec
nous notre nouveau marché de
restauration qui date de juillet 2021 on
va vers ça on va encore progresser et
tout ça a pris gelé parce que nous avons
souhaité je l'ai les tarifs de la
restauration scolaire pour la deuxième
année dans l'exercice de vos fonctions
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu peur
physiquement non êtes-vous un maire
heureux oui très bien merci François
Marton c'était des réponses très courtes
vous avez bien joué le jeu question à
deux mères
les règles du jeu
en tout cas merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je le rappelle vous êtes le
maire de Guyancourt